okay let me explain
i'm gonna accept a challenge
when i'm blindfolded so i'll basically
like have my mouse over this
and then put the blindfold on and then
accept the challenge
it's gonna be 960. i won't know the
starting position i will only have
the keyboard to try
to try and play legal moves
um i won't even know the time control
but i'll have the clock command so i'll
be able to
see how much time i have in the
beginning um so that'll be fine
and
i think that's all
does that work game storage keemstar
okay
find the keyboard
so i don't know if i'm white or black
why ten minutes zero seconds
beautiful back ten minutes zero seconds
barely hear it man
find the volume
d4
oh i'm black okay good
d4 d4
where's my mic
hopefully i'm speaking into the mic
so i'm black white plays d4
um i'm gonna try and
i should try knight moves first like
knight g6
um
[Music]
i could play d5 but
let's try knight f6
f6 oh god i forgot to change it back
from giggle horsey
so i have a knight on
[Music]
i had a knight it was on either g8 or e8
c4
but i can't be both
so we just have like i could play
budapest if i play e5
i feel like i should play e6 here
and hopefully i have like a bishop to
develop or something
e6 and hopefully my opponent will give
me some clues too based on what they
develop
so i don't know the back rank at all
[Music]
and my opponent has a nylon e1 or g1 3
b3
b3
okay
i'm inclined to play d5 first
at least we get some like stable pawn
structure
and then i'll start playing around with
what pieces i can move
but it's really annoying my opponent's
not moving any pawns or any um any
pieces
it is annoying that they're moving only
pawns
white nine minutes nine seconds
black nine minutes 29 seconds
giga4cf3
yeah that's so annoying okay big b7 no
um
can i play
so if i don't have a dark square bishop
can my dark square bishop be
it's not on f8 or
it could be on b8
let's play c6
c6
so i have a semi soft setup
dark for bishop can't be f8 or
d8
so it has to be b8 or h8
bishop c3
bishop c3
so that means there is a bishop on
e1 or a1
oh do i have a bishop on eight
bishop c3 i'm gonna play um
b6 v6
and next move i'm gonna try bishop b7
probably
so bishop c3
this is so difficult
but it requires logic
i'm imagining one wait what
king g1 okay so the knight was on g8
initially
which
wait
so the king had to start on f
f1 and f8 so my king's on f8
white played kim ji won maybe attempting
to castle there has to be a rook okay so
king has to be between the rooks so
there's rook on h1 h8
i think my opponent tried to castle but
didn't know to bring the rook over the
king
um so i'm gonna play bishop b7
bishop b okay so
that gives me information if i can't
play bishop b7
i have rook on h a king on f8
bishop has to be on e8
can i play bishop d6 bishop okay so my
bishop was on b8 why has bishop on
[Music]
b1
which
means there's a queen
queen on d8 or c8
and then rook on d8 or c8
okay
beginning to feel the position a bit
better
c5
c5
so it's yeah the c5 supported by the
queen or the
uh the rook
um
i think i'll
no should i take no i shouldn't take
because bishop on c3 oh there's a bishop
on c3 though i can take
b takes c5
ah
but if i take again there's bishop f6
and then i lose my bishop on c5
so i'll play bishop to i could move back
to b8 maybe
wait what's on eight though i could have
a rook on him
wait a minute
also oh where's my second
bishop
night
c7 okay
i might castle soon
if that's even legal
wait
so white has a bishop on c3
and
b1
oh b1 aimed at h7 knight on f3
g5
uh h6 probably
h6
i still don't know where all the pieces
are she takes f6
okay let's try queen f6 no so queen has
to be on
eight or
c8
so i have to take with pawn
gf6
g takes f6
king is on f8
work on h8 okay so knight's attacked by
two different pawns
white seven minutes queen takes f6
ah the queen's on eight
oh no
i can't queen's like castle
wait so what's on d8
bishop had to be
i have bishop on e8
this is really bad
bishop on e8
the king's on g1
[Music]
oh this is rough
okay let's take the knight i guess
h takes g5
and q7
queen takes h king e7
okay
at this point i'm just trying to survive
so i have bishop on e8 queen on eight
bishman c7
i believe the rook is on c8 which means
i have a knight in
not on d8 or c8
okay
and my king side's just destroyed here
h4
g4 g4
kings on g1
white six minutes 21 seconds
black five minutes nine seconds okay
gotta move faster too
queen's on aids
where's my horsey
i have to play like king
[Music]
d
wait
queen g7
queen g7 is terrifying
maybe i can play like g3
g3
trying something
and it takes each one is past okay queen
b8 queen v8
at least i have a battery
[Music]
uh the bishop no the bishop's not on e1
anymore because it traded go eric you
keep my love of chess alive oh thank you
that's good to hear
giga4cd3
white five minutes seven seconds my
gigahorse d3 okay so my knights on c8
kind of d8
um
um
[Music]
queen's on g7 so i could take the
[Music]
hopefully this isn't a blunder bishop
takes g3
man it's getting so messy
my pieces are so badly placed though
i have to do something like contortions
like how do i
how do i activate my lights for a bishop
because my f pawns pinned my pawns on c6
wait so where is where white's remaining
what
e4 e4
e4
is there still a bishop on b1
what if i just take that
d take c4
have a rook on d8
i'm hitting the line on d3
wait there's bishop on
oh there's rook on d1
queen g5 check
uh fancy but i have f6
f6 i have queen in g7 bishop f7
beginning to sense what the position is
now
white four minutes two seconds
black three minutes fifty four seconds i
don't know if there's if there's
increments
but the g7 check yeah okay bishop f7
bishop f7
so i have pawns on e6 f6 e4 c6
a7
pawn e4 still hitting the knight
queen on b8 defends my bishop
ready to play rook g8 maybe
my knight's still kind of
dominated by the c5 pawn
but what's white snacks move
i had knight before maybe i have even
queen f4
okay let's play rook g8 rook g8 hitting
the queen
also kind of skewering
helping defend my bishop
queen h7 yeah so i could take the knight
yeah why not ed3 he takes d3
up a piece
momentum shifting
and my knight's still kind of bad
so there's
i think there's a bishop on b1 and rook
on d1 so
bishop queen of four queen f4
the pawn i think the pawn still on each
four i don't think i moved to h5 yet
oh type
could i have taken on d4 with a rook
because it works on d8
i mean ready to take next move queen f2
is also in the error
we might see rook f1 here rook have one
queen e3 check
white one minute 29 seconds
black three minutes 38 seconds okay
plenty of time
rook f1
queen e3 queen e3 check king h1
uh i'm trying to envision the f-file
i think everything's fine queen d3 queen
takes d3
okay so i'm up two pieces
queen takes d3 oh i forgot the queen
could move backwards
ah
i'm still alive though
i just have two pieces for a queen now
i have um funny move bishop e5
take six takes
wait
where's white's last minor piece
i have a bishop on f7
we do have three pieces for the queen
no i lost a rook earlier
wait so
[Music]
bb5 takes takes text
let's try bishop b5
bishop p5
queen a6
oh dear
bishop d4
i thought there's a pawn d4
rook d3
did i just miss a chance to take
oh
it should be five
fishing p5 gosh
that's on c8 king on e7
[Music]
works on g67 check
oh no
queen b7
bishop e5
queen b7 check
rook d3 rooks on d3
that's not good
i have to play king f8 king fx who's my
knight
queen takes ca check yeah
oh the position was good too
um king
g7 king g7
so he's working two bishops for
queen and two rooks queen takes c6 oh
dear
okay luke h8
queen e4
queen e4
ponce on h4
[Music]
just play like bishop
bishop it bishop b8
kg1
a5
queen e3
rook takes h4
rook d7
hmm
bishop e5
rook fd1
f5
queen g5 check
oh no
ah
[Music]
king f8 rook d8 check
bishop e8 rook takes e8 check
king takes e8
d h king f7 queen e7 check
king takes easy what why timeout i just
went on time i was about to resign
what just happened
what just happened
i have four seconds left
there's no increments wow
opponent was trying to dirty flag me man
it's so bright
wow
queenie seven czech game samuel pancake
creator